Khloe Kardashian reveals the racy secret
to her long-distance relationship with
Tristan Thompson I just want to live my
life and be happy the reality star and
her NBA pro boyfriend are expecting
their first child together it's just a
ball and are living together full-time
and I love it but before the 33 year
olds mama-to-be moved in with her man
the lovebirds were making it work long
distance and on Monday Chloe reveals how
offering up this sexy advice quote drop
little hints about something you want to
try in the bedroom next time you see
them it will give you both something to
look forward to until you're together
again that's the fun of it and while the
blonde beauty admitted the distance can
be hard she added quote you get to
appreciate one another on a deeper level
without the distractions of physical
getting in the way whatever they did it
seems to have worked and while Chloe has
yet to confirm the baby news herself she
recently shut down fans on Instagram
when they claimed to spy her baby bump
in this pic writing in the comments
section quote it's just the way the
shirt is designed et learned last month
that Koko is expecting I'm having so
much fun just days after it was revealed
that her younger sister Kylie Jenner is
also pregnant a source told ET quote
it's going to be a very busy time for
the kardashian-jenner family everyone is
thrilled
[Music]